tu es quand même de paillettes norma
bigamie rsa lui c'est inné serait et
maurice prend bri donc de découvrir avec
une vidéo qui a fait le buzz est ce que
cette vidéo a mis des paillettes
d'anthony bell à nice sept cent mille
paillettes dans ma vie ces coupes
elle a totalement vidée pas être dans ma
vie alors sans la vidéo j'avais cent
cinquante mille abonnés sur instagram
est aujourd'hui alors oui je te parle
j'en ai 7 500 milles cdoi sont 27 ans
kevin bon cheval est bizarre moi la
belle chute l'humoriste et du coup ce
genre on attend tous d'avoir un peu ce
ce buzz ou cet énorme coup de lumière
sur notre choix je n'appellerais pas ça
un buzz puisque j'avais le boss un peu
éphémère nation ce truc du moment et
apprend l'oubli alors que moi c'était
vraiment mon travail c'est ce que je
fais parce que mon art je vis de ça et
en fait ce gros coup de lumière m'a
permis de mener
énormément de followers et du coup c'est
maintenant que tout se joue tu vois
genre c'est là au fond que jean montre
qu'est ce que je fais de quoi je suis
capable de travailler de dingue pour
amener tous et jean barbon spectacle
j'ai commencé à l'humour il ya cinq ans
au début je travaillais à côté vous été
animatrice entre les vacances je fais de
la cohésion mais tout mais j'ai toujours
voulu faire de l'humour est vrai que
c'est un peu compliqué au début de dire
que tu vas te lancer dans cette carrière
parce que tu sais très bien que ben
c'est vraiment un certain tu sais pas
quelle manche et à réussir est ce que tu
vas gagner ta vie est ce que c'est
compliqué et au final j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir des parents qui ont suivi à fond
j'ai fait les cours florent
j'ai commencé à faire des scènes
ouvertes qui j'ai commencé à rentrer au
diabète obésité et j'ai continué à faire
ça jusqu'au jour j sur cette fameuse
vidéo qui pour moi entre noah faut que
celui 10h je me suis dit ok je n'ai je
vais regarder ça m'a fait rire tu vois
parce que franchement moulures au
plafond le mot me fait rire décor est ce
qu'on habitait visé des moulures au
plafond kevin on habite dans l'es3 c'est
ça que tu moi toi je me suis assez cool
ce sera une vidéo de plus soit je
m'attendais pas à ce que ce soir j j'ai
été choqué
il existe vraiment effectivement c'est
mais c'est mon côté air est à la fois
aussi surtout je pense qu'il faut dire
c'est avant tout mon mari et m me tuer
c'est mon mari et du coup ils existent
vraiment et c'est vraiment de délire
c'est comme ça qu'on c'est comme ça
qu'on fonctionne regarde moi comme je
suis sereine comme un bon tu ne trouves
sexé m'est intériorise beaucoup
là-dessus valoir arriver les dalles ans
mercy west mais si tu veux en parler
les paillettes c'est trop drôle et une
loi qui vinifie servent souvent top
tweets pour vous et quand j'ai montré
mes followers qui qui augmentait 15 0
mais c'est moi qui en top twin peaks et
kevin céphise l état en folie et valeur
dans la salle république quand on va aux
républiques au théâtre où je veux jouer
du coup on descend directement dans la
grande salle c'est du coup j'ai la
chance de jouer dans la salle de 500
places c'était prévu dans la salle de
200 et ça a tellement
fonctionner les gens ont tellement aimé
que j'ai la chance de pouvoir remplir la
chance en place trois fois par semaine
allez on y va c'est facile là c'est
l'entraidé voire 6 c est parti bienvenue
république vidéo sur instagram
il va avoir 100 personnes qu'il aime
trois qui nous est revenu les tout cas
je ne sais pas en vrai ils sont chez eux
il le pense pas mais là là c'est direct
une vanne et tu vois direct c'est ça
fera ou pas s'imaginer à l'arrière
notamment
et sinon moi j'ai une vidéo des failles
est en fait j'avais peur les réseaux
sociaux on peut s'acheter l'ehpad
j'ai un peu peur parce que je sais que
on peut avoir beaucoup de nouveaux
commentaires de la critique et settat et
mais j'ai trop de chance parce que ça se
passe tellement bien contre vidéo et je
voyais aimé par marion cotillard truc à
te jure ça arrive je ne sais pas tu sais
pas j'en ai fait ma mère la série
toujours c'est la folie le churn à
apprendre un truc mais ça soit en plus
que jamais je savais pas du tout et
c'est moi genre jeu là que j'ai vu que
ma robe du soir c'était miss univers qui
avait laïque et ma ma vidéo
et puis j'ai eu plein de miss en même
temps qu'ils me qui sont venus flou et
caetera et je trouvais ça trop dingue
mais tu me diras marion cotillard c'est
incroyable sérieux non de temps 38e